[Music]
i'll miss you
[Music]
speaking of the swiss alps man what
on tock in the cliff of us laughing at
the
olympic skier
i saw that one too came up right
and speaking of the word came i felt
like we
we failed to consider something so
massively important what
all right this is juvenile as hell but
i just picked like when i saw that flag
hit him in the nuts again i'm like did
that [ __ ] just like smack the [ __ ] out of
his entire body like when that flag came
up
is that why he went
like did he quiver because he hit his
ball so hard that all the semen in his
body just
so you're saying he stopped
not because
of the pain
but because he just came so hard he hit
a big o he
he climaxed that hard cause his i can't
even oh no no no yeah i can't even do it
oh that's what he sounds like like his
voice like wavers
it's like if you took like a saw and
like you know just
yeah yeah
[Laughter]
like it was like he
he finished finished
yeah it probably was a little bit
painful too yeah but when you finish
that hard yeah yeah yeah
there's a little bit of pain and
pleasure at that point
so stupid i just picked that flag coming
up and just in his pants [ __ ]
just spiderman giant look yeah
like
just just
sticking to his legs
[Laughter]
like
oh sure
oh miss yo
he's lighting a cigarette
now the host as he was saying that
he was like rolling down his boxers and
like opening up his leg there's a woman
there pulling one of those
pulling one of those flags back
and as soon as the broadcast ended she
just let it go
something of bamboo yeah yeah just
oh miss you
this it is so dumb he's just rolling his
[ __ ] boxers down and there's just
this there's just this icicle
it's like a frozen um yeah just
just hold it
like a radio antenna there you go
yeah so stupid
i mean the force it had to have because
the way he like
keeled over yeah there was mel c yeah
oh messi
he was like
that's how it sounded
your body only does that
because you've been hitting the nuts
before you've never quivered yeah yeah
oh trust me i've been hitting the nuts
oh yeah after last week yeah
i'm not sure i'll ever recover actually
yeah well you know
because now that's all you want to do
yeah exactly
[Laughter]
yeah i brought that thing home
can you imagine being like like nine
years old in like third grade or
whatever people are
thinking this would be funny sack tap
yeah stop someone's sack testing stop
stop doing that
stop
don't stab me again y'all
i hate when you guys do that
or whatever i would not see it coming
right now if you did it right now
what if it's darker they're like ew
it's like darker it's like sack tap they
just hit him he's like
do it again
direct eye gun
oh no
oh he starts walking towards them stop
look stop the wide legs
do it again do it again do it again hit
me again tap me yeah
teach uh miss erinson noel's really
freaking me out right now miss aronson
he won't stack tap me
jacob if you want to do saktaps you have
to sack tap noelle
what no no
you want to play a funny game
type your classmates
you already did it once right we'll do
it again then attacked at me sex tape
you don't get you don't you don't get it
he looks like he's liking it
don't be silly no one likes a sap tap
yeah no one likes a sack tap do it again
noel
and the kids start popping up me next
yeah me next get me next jacob i hate
sack taps
licking each other's teeth
what
the kids like lick each other's teeth
why
because it's gross
yeah it is weird yeah
yeah that got weirder yeah
because it's funny now because
someone was like yeah yeah imagine a kid
getting sacked or what
that was me
i know
i just like to imagine
a hundred thousand people simultaneously
going huh
it's like driving
at work yeah wherever they're listening
to this and just being like
excuse me
yeah
yeah
[Laughter]
they have that in their car they have a
that [ __ ] in their lap yeah a big-ass
turntable yeah when they're listening to
a podcast
[Laughter]
yeah like
did you ever skateboard
i didn't i'm just picturing like a you
know like a 14 year old skater
just like busting his board on purpose
yeah big ass board slide
i guess he's just dude that's like the
fourth time you've done that are you
good are you good no i'm not
i gotta go again go for it again
dude that's like 40 nut strips dude what
are you doing to your boards they're so
weak
left them all out in the rain
why
do they you can use mine if you want
no i'd rather use a soggy one
hosing them down yeah
they get there to the skate park early
early to the [ __ ] school wherever
they're skating this [ __ ] the next day
he's there ahead of time he's got like a
small chisel and a hammer just going
down the center of the board dude what
are you doing
oh
making it stronger dude your board looks
decrepit what the [ __ ] is that even a
skateboard what are we using
that looks like a
like the seat from a like a old boat or
something dude
why are you using a sheet of
of styrofoam
yo dude
is that a boat ore from 1850
that's not a skateboard man playing tony
hawk with your boys yeah dude stop doing
the sack tab you do it every time
yo why do you keep busting the board on
the rails
cause it's
fun watching the guy watching the guy on
the screen
nut himself and
everyone everyone's trying to like like
oh let's see who's got the higher score
yeah my turn yeah
oh
just three minutes how sick was that
three minutes
just yeah
just oh trey flip no slide 360 flip out
stick here noel your turn
sick nice
just punching myself in the nut to stop
oh
dude you don't get any points for that
that's zero points why do you keep doing
that
doesn't that hurt dude
not if you keep going
punching yourself in the nuts is crazy
dude yeah
that's such a good way to get out of a
fight yeah the [ __ ] did you say to me
you just back up dude
[Laughter]
oh what are you doing
ow
just run full speed at a [ __ ] stop
light and just jump up and split your
legs in the air
oh
[Laughter]
remember that fellas if you ever get
yourself in a tough situation just punch
the [ __ ] out of your own dick yeah
this guy's [ __ ] insane
damn
or like
you're getting all aggro
your girlfriend's like butting your own
dick
damn how's he doing that flexible too
you're getting all aggro and your girl's
like
stop babe don't do it and then she just
gets down on one knee and just starts
punching the [ __ ] out of your balls with
two hands
holy [ __ ] lady what are you doing it's
the only way to get him to calm down
to calm down
you